[Musique]
l'idée est digne d'un roman de science
fiction créé un robot à partir de
cellules de grenouilles moitié machine
moitié vivent ce robot est aujourd'hui
bien réel
conçu par des chercheurs américains
cette drôle de créature c'est l'exil au
bo
microscopiques et sant andreu nages il
mesure moins d'un millimètre la taille
idéale ont voyagé à l'intérieur du corps
humain
cette nouvelle forme de vie bouge marche
et peut déplacer des objets en cas de
bris elle est même capable de s'auto
réparer dans un premier temps sa
construction est purement virtuel fait à
l'ordinateur à l'aide d'un algorithme on
simule le comportement des cellules de
grenouilles celle de la peau et du coeur
avec ces informations en mémoire
l'ordinateur sait prédire leur mouvement
en fonction de leur forme
il fait donc des milliers d'assemblage
il identifie les configurations les plus
efficaces celles capables de réaliser
une tâche précise comme celle d'avancer
en ligne droite par exemple une fois les
configuration optimale identifier les
chercheurs passe du virtuel à la réalité
[Musique]
à l'aide d'une pince et d'une électrode
des biologistes manipulent les cellules
les assemble de manière à obtenir la
forme prédéfinis paru super calculateur
les cellules travaillent ensemble celle
de la peau se lit forme une structure
tridimensionnelle les cellules du coeur
elles permettent au groupe de se
déplacer grâce aux contractions qu'elles
produisent
le tout donne naissance au xénon beau
[Musique]
grâce à sa réserve d'énergie
il peut survivre pendant une dizaine de
jours dans l'avenir ces créatures
pourrait transporter des médicaments
dans le corps humain ou y voyager pour
nettoyer la paroi des artères